c'est l'un des joyaux de sens le marché
couvert situé face à la cathédrale un
édifice construit à l'emplacement de
l'ancien Hôtel Dieu en 1882 symbole de
l'avant-garde de l'architecture
métallique mais regarder de plus près à
l'intérieur le diamant a sérieusement
perdu de son éclat la peinture des
frîchis s'écaille les allées sont exigu
c'est l'hôtel des courant d'air et le
sol est en piteux état on s'enfonce
dedans c'est comme la pâte à modeler les
tables S fonce donc on peut pas nettoyer
correctement une chape étanche va donc
être coulée les colonnes repeintes les
étales fixes des commerçants àrandi et
des doubles portes installées à chaque
entrée coût des travaux près de 3
millions d'euros imputés dans le budget
2015 la rénovation a étit prévu depuis
de nombreuses années mais n'avait encore
jamais été entreprise il faut dire que
la question est sensible il y a 50 ans
la municipalité l'a appris à ses dépens
et le conseil municipal des années 60 64
pour être précis a décidé de construire
un N nouveau marché couvert ailleurs pas
en cœur de ville les commerçants du
centreeville les non sédentaires les
sédentaires l'ofice de tourisme ont
protesté et
finalement on l'a gardé et en 1975 il
était classé à l'inire des monuments
historiques avec ses travaux la ville de
Sens espère aussi réinvestir l'espace et
organiser de nouvelles manifestations
comme aux grandes heures du marché
couvert dans les années 50 on a eu fit
un temps l'intérieur qui avait vu des
matchs de catch des choses comme ça on
souhaiterait réanimer un peu le
centreville c'est le poumon de la ville
ici hein pendant les travaux les
commerçants vont être hébergés sous un
chapitaau place Garibaldi à 300 m de là
ils espèrent ne pas pâtir de cette
délocalisation et attendent avec
impatience de refaire leur entrée dans
la halle début décembre